salud en directo américa de france 24
más romeros a la con nosotros ya en
nuestro estudio mar volvamos a tratar un
tema que hemos hablado varias veces las
vacunas por supuesto contra el kobe 19 y
el psico el ciclo menstrual qué
novedades tenemos buenos días raúl es
pues es un estudio coordinado por el
csic de españa el consejo superior de
investigaciones científicas y que se
publicó en el american journal of
obstetrics gynecology
llegaron a una conclusión interesante
que nos puede dar pistas hacia el futuro
y es que detectaron que los cambios en
el ciclo menstrual que algunas mujeres y
personas que instruyan han detectado
después de vacunarse contra el commit 19
podría depender del momento en el que se
aplica esta vacuna en el ciclo menstrual
tiene varias fases las personas que se
vacunaron en la fase lútea que es
después de la ovulación no sintieron
ningún cambio en cambio las mujeres y
las personas que se vacunaron en la fase
folicular que es la que viene previa a
la ovulación sintieron de media un día
más de ciclo menstrual su ciclo
menstrual se alargó un día y un 11% más
de un 11% de hecho se les alargó el
ciclo menstrual más de 8 días es un
porcentaje para nada insignificante cada
vez se ve más que estos ciclos
menstruales que suponen cambios
hormonales importantes en los cuerpos
durante todo un mes influyen en muchos
procesos fisiológicos y la vacunación
podría ser una de ellas este estudio se
hizo con datos anónimos proporcionados
por una aplicación de salud menstrual de
registro del ciclo menstrual algunas de
las limitaciones que podemos decir es
que por ahora sólo fueron 371 personas
las que participaron que es una muestra
grande pero todavía no tan grande como
que lo que hacer para tener conclusiones
más grandes y que cada persona reportaba
sus síntomas su ciclo y que eso puedes
puede dar lugar a algunos sesgos a la
hora de evaluar pues las personas lo que
sintieron y lo que tuvieron pero bueno
es bueno ver que hay partes de la comuna
científica que están recibiendo no toda
esa información todas esas denuncias y
esas críticas que se hicieron desde la
sociedad civil y eso nos puede empezar a
dar pistas no sobre qué es lo que puede
estar pasando con estos cambios y
siguiendo con las vacunas contra de kobe
19 más las regulador europeo aprobó hoy
a los refuerzos contra la variante
omicron así es raúl es una noticia de
ayer de la europea de medicamentos una
vacuna de las farmacéuticas país de ibai
un tec contra particularmente las
variantes vea 4 y vea 5 las sub
variantes de la variante o micro no se
aprobó para todos los mayores de 12 años
que hayan recibido al menos ya una
vacuna antes contra el cubit 19 además
de hace poco se aprobaron también
vacunas the fighter iv de modernas
contra la su variante ba1 de o micro en
todas estas pues se dirigen a esta
variante lado micro en que ha sido la
dominante la protagonista de los
contagios en todo
2029 han habido ciertas críticas por
ejemplo en eeuu porque se han aprobado
se ha dado luz verde a estas vacunas sin
estudios en humanos específicos de estas
vacunas contra las sus variantes pero
desde aquí queríamos recordar que por
ejemplo es algo que sucede muy
habitualmente en las vacunas contra la
gripe por ejemplo que cada año se
modifican para luchar contra variantes
específicas sin tener que pasar por ese
proceso que sabemos que puede ser muy
largo entonces bueno llamado a la calma
es normal que esto suceda y ojalá pueda
ir sucediendo a medida que vayan
apareciendo también nuevas variantes así
es más 2019 creo que se le fueron diez
años
perdón pero no importa eso eso de ser
porque no ha comido mucho chocolate esta
mañana amar usted puede creer de la
energía necesita la energía y ya
saliendo obviamente el programa nos
tomamos un rico chocolate caliente para
combatir el frío gota porque eso lo digo
porque hoy es el día internacional del
chocolate y como él y como le quería
decir hay gente que no le gusta pues
este respirable pero lo que se pierde lo
que se pierden efectivamente no sabemos
qué es un alimento que a todos nos da
mucha felicidad y ese indudablemente va
a ser uno de sus principales beneficios
más allá de todo lo demás que hablemos
aquí no es uno de los alimentos que
siempre ha estado sumergido en esos
debates de si es saludable o no es
saludable y la primera gran aclaración
que quiero hacerte a ti también a
nuestra audiencia es que es muy distinto
el cacao y el chocolate entonces vamos a
hacer esa diferencia el cacao es el
fruto de origen tropical que se tritura
del que sale un cacao en polvo también
una especie de manteca con la que luego
se hace el chocolate tiene muchos
beneficios hablamos por ejemplo de una
alta presencia de antioxidantes que
reducen el daño que con el tiempo se va
se va haciendo en las células células
perdón también tiene mucha fibra todo
esto ayuda pues mejora la salud
cardiovascular también mejor salud
digestiva entonces tiene amplios
beneficios que han estado estudiados y
registrados sin embargo qué pasa que
cuando se procesa se pierde el 60 por
ciento de estos antioxidantes por
ejemplo y además lo que se hace es
añadir se les grasas aceites no por
ejemplo también azúcar y muchas veces
leche y estos tipos de productos que se
encuentran entonces en el chocolate ya
sabemos todos que no son tan buenos para
la salud y de hecho pueden llegar hasta
contrarrestar todo eso bueno qué nos
aporta el cacao no por ejemplo en lo que
respecta a la salud cardiovascular
azúcares y grasas pues sabemos que no es
lo mejor especialmente en exceso también
contrarresta sabemos lo bueno de esta
salud digestiva precisamente porque
pueden llegar a alterar la micro vía
intestinal este tipo de productos
también pues por supuesto si se consumen
en grandes cantidades marc pero hay
alguna forma con todo lo que está
diciendo de comer chocolate quedándonos
con lo bueno del cacao porque casi que
en vez de cacao sale el cacao pero lo
que terminamos comiendo no tiene nada
que ver que una fruta exactamente
entonces bueno yo he traído esto para
cerrar y para darte una buena noticia
para irnos con un buen sabor de boca y
saber que tenemos alguna alguna solución
no por supuesto primero comer este tipo
de productos con moderación pero más
allá de esto sabiendo que no nos podemos
alejar tanto a veces primero intentar
que el porcentaje de cacao sea lo más
elevado posible al menos por encima del
65% para intentar equilibrar estos
beneficios contra lo nocivo pero por
supuesto cuanto más alto mejor incluso
sabemos que a veces este gusto amargos
para los valientes pero bueno aquí hemos
venido a jugar no con este tipo de cosas
también se pueden revisar los
ingredientes intentar que el azúcar
aparezca como lo más bajo pues que lo
primero sea productos directamente
derivados del cacao incorporar el cacao
en polvo directamente y evitar el
chocolate blanco que no tiene nada de la
parte beneficiosa marc como siempre
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud ahorita nos tomamos
el chocolate cuando bueno